welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and looking ahead to Marvel phase
four one major character who appears to
have trouble fitting into any of this is
big Brucie after endgame what the hell
is hope supposed to do now maybe this is
Mark Ruffalo's punishment for being such
a huge spoiler everybody the fact
remains that Ruffalo still has one movie
left on his sixth picture contract and
the MCU has got to want to feature the
guy in some way considering other other
Big Tymers are dusting like 50% of the
flies really it's just a question of how
but then at d23 Kevin Feige announced
she-hulk is coming to Disney Plus
sometime in the next few years probably
2022 or later so does that tell us where
Hulk is going well maybe butthole can
see Hulk aren't really known for
appearing in Marvel Comics together that
much Bruce Banner Jennifer Walters I
have really distinct appeals and
separate adventures except for team ups
but it is safe to assume that they're
MCU destinies will be linked in some way
so I'm gonna break down what Marvel
might in store for the Hulk and she-hulk
and I'm gonna try to do it all before
Ruffalo accidentally blurts it all out
in an interview spoiler warning in case
I'm right and thanks to privacy comm for
sponsoring this episode more details
later and how they can help you protect
your online spending okay so when we
last saw Hulk and Avengers in game he
had evolved into his professor Hulk
state the mind of Bruce Banner fused
with the body of the whole years I've
been treating the Hulk like he's some
kind of disease something they get rid
of but then I start looking at him as
the cure 18 months in a gambler I put
the brains and the Brawn together and
now they get me best of both worlds and
I had to cut away from that clip before
the Russos and a few stairs in the
camera it's actually that gamma
radiation that led Hulk to step forward
to wield Starks infinity gauntlet and
snap everyone back but seriously
wounding his arm in the process so that
it remained in the sling in the final
scene of the film co director Joe Russo
confirmed that this wound is permanent
saying he's lost an arm he's damaged
himself I don't know what's interesting
that's permanent damage the same way
that it was permanent damage with Bannos
it's irreversible damage his arm if you
noticed is a lot skinnier it's blackened
so he loses a lot of strength there
Russo went on to say maybe someone helps
him repair that maybe someone gives him
a new arm I have no idea where that
character goes from here the nice thing
is we didn't have to pay attention to
where it goes after this we just tried
to tell a satisfying ending
so the Russo's may not have thought it
all out but they essentially gave the
the best character trait ever an
unhealable wound from Avengers in 2012
through endgame Hulk's Ark was a gradual
evolution of humanity and balance
between the split identities with each
movie Hulk became less of a rage monster
and more of a humanistic manchild
until finally an end game he simply
becomes a green Ruffalo or complete but
now with a permanent wound there are all
kinds of places his story can go Tony
Stark did become Iron Man until he got a
hole in his chest Bucky Barnes is
constantly losing an arm through his eye
Banner could try to replace his arm with
a cybernetic prosthetic which could lead
him to Wakanda where Shuri forged a
vibranium arm for Bucky that could
suggest to Hulk appearance in the
upcoming black panther 2 there are also
all kinds of remedies across the galaxy
rocket had a spare eyeball for Thor and
Captain Marvel referred to Zora and
elixirs and endgame suggesting Hulk
might again leave earth and join up with
the guardians of the galaxy in their
third film or again with Thor in Thor
love and thunder of course banner might
also try to repair his arm by examining
his unique gamma-irradiated blood and
tissue is could actually be a way Marvel
introduces she-hulk because banners new
balance with his Hulk form is actually
one of the most well known aspects of
she Hulk's character I'm actually gonna
explain everything you need to know
about she-hulk but before we continue
thank you to privacy comm for sponsoring
this episode
privacy calm is a free service that lets
you buy things online using virtual
cards instead of your real credit card
info protecting yourself on the internet
it's essentially like a digital burner
card with limits that you control it's
great you don't worry about shady
vendors using your card info to buy like
20 whole cans for themselves what do you
need that many whole cans for word
actually you know what I don't need to
know the answer bet I already know but
also privacy icon lets you avoid having
to hand over the keys to your finances
every time you sign up for a
subscription to something which you know
they're just waiting asthenia before we
have a chance to cancel it so for
example I have set up an account with
privacy and I've linked my bank account
and created a card specifically for my
monthly Netflix subscription payment for
this virtual card I'm setting the limit
to just above my normal monthly
subscription rates so that way someone
tries to use this privacy card number
again or overcharge it privacy will
notify you that they blacked it because
the spending limit was already reached
see it's simple it's fast just one click
and again it's free it is a special deal
for you folks first time customers who
sign up with privacy calm slash new rock
stars will get five dollars off their
first purchase with privacy calm so go
to private
c-calm / new rock stars again that's PRI
BAC y comm /n e WR Ock SD ARS to get
five dollars off your first purchase now
okay so a bit of background on she-hulk
she is Jennifer Walters rue spanners
cousin lawyer who gets shot by criminals
loses a lot of blood Bruce gives her a
transfusion with his gamma-irradiated
blood and when the criminals come back
to try to finish the job Jennifer's
anger transforms her into she-hulk
but in later issues she gets a blood
disease in a serum from Morbius the
living vampire allows her to control
when she can transform back and forth
between Jennifer and she hold in
throughout her comic appearances she
tends to just stay in shield form get to
anyway to practice law kick ass and
break the fourth wall on occasion to
satirize comics as a whole now Marvel in
the past has had limited options for how
to feature Hulk in movies because
technically Universal seems to own the
distribution rights to any movie with
Hulk in the title the same I assumed was
true for she-hulk but maybe they worked
out a deal now that she's gonna be on
Disney Plus so let's assume that hoax
next movie appearance embraces his dead
arm like a Thor 11 Thunder he could
fight alongside Thor Valkyrie Korg and
meek as his rotting flesh is dragging
along and to Kane maybe rigor mortis
spasms to accidentally punch Thor out of
frame again but the theme of Thor love
and thunder from what I can tell me
about how to balance power dynamics when
love an illness enter the equation like
in the Mighty Thor comic storyline that
Taika Waititi is adapting Jane Foster
powers up into lady Thor to escape from
her cancer which unfortunately resets
her chemo with each powerup my theory is
that Thor will actually hand over his
power to Jane as a way to help cure her
and perhaps banner will witness this and
be inspired to use his own super powers
for healing purposes and based on his
own research into his own blood
maybe he'll offer a transfusion to
Jennifer Walters the timing would work
out since Thor 11 Thunder won't come
until November 20 21 and she-hulk must
be coming to Disney Plus sometime after
that
and this will draw a logical progression
from Hulk's state after endgame through
a natural reunion with four that were
all dying to see who his connection with
she hoax origin in the Marvel comics and
this would set up she-hulk not as a
replacement of Hulk in the MCU but as a
colleague because like Thor there
doesn't have to be just one of each
title and characters don't have to be
Dee powered so that other characters can
be powerful and while Bruce Banner could
live on as the insu's thickest fingered
this Jennifer Walters can represent
everyone in court in the comics she
whole joins the Heroes for Hire and
later on she provides legal assistance
to superheroes seeking to avoid
registration during the Civil War era
along with Matt Murdock she's Marvel's
sharpest attorney so while she Hoke
seems to be a no-brainer leader for a
future a force lineup like the one posed
by that shot in endgame she could also
be the ideal way to reboot Marvel's
lawyers like daredevil in the MCU and
Marvel is gonna need all the lawyers it
can if it wants to get back spider-man
how do you want the MCU to future hold
and she Hulk in the future comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at a vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
breakdowns of everything marvel thank
you for joining me and let's just hope
bye guys she-hulk plan is to not just
put Mark Ruffalo and a wig it probably
won't go over well
[Music]